you made space waves for fifty thousand
dollars correct but you started with ten
right
can you talk about how you raised the
first ten thousand yeah so the first ten
thousand was really just
a lot of asking friends and family and
calling up different people and
connections we had we did at Indiegogo
fundraising campaign that went all right
but we didn't want to you know we didn't
want to settle and we're like no we need
10K to like do this film so we ended up
doing like a garage sale as well which
was really cool and that brought in
close to a thousand dollars and we just
had people donate stuff and then we set
up this big garage sale and sold a bunch
of stuff and so that helped and we just
tried to get creative and then Andrew
who's the producer him and I both put in
money ourselves
um and so it was just it was just a big
combination of things had Andrew ever
made a film before
uh he had made just short films just
same as same as me so you were I think
he had made I think he had made um kind
of a 20 or 30 minute short film and then
he had done a longer documentary back in
high school as well
um a part of I guess high school project
but this was both of our first features
so with the first 10 000 what was the
hardest hurdle to get over to raise that
money like where did the bulk of that 10
000 come from the Indiegogo
um not it didn't necessarily come from
the Indiegogo I think it I think the
bulk of it came from our parents and
grandparents and like those closest to
us who donated maybe a few thousand each
so that was probably where most of it
came from so yeah just people that
really believed in us and that have been
in our corner corner since since day one
and did you have to sit them down and
convince them or they knew this was
something you were planning to do with
or without them uh definitely the latter
I mean they you know I mean especially I
can just speak for my parents like they
know whenever I put my put my focus and
attention on something I'm gonna follow
through and do it so
um yeah they were supportive from the
beginning
did they say you sure you want to do
this or they were just like no we're
behind you they can't really convince me
you know they're just kind of like oh
well Spencer's gonna do his thing so
yeah great parents though love you Mom
and Dad what did you find is the most
effective way to ask for money
yeah
I that's hard it's really hard there's
no easy way I don't think to ask for
money but I think I think the best way
to do it
is to share the vision for the film
first and share what's the message why
are you doing this you know that's the
most important thing if it's just oh I
want to make a cool movie you know
that's okay that's one thing but if
you're saying I want to tell this story
and I want to impact people on I want to
influence people and I want to you know
uh just
I have something to say to the world
that's a lot more enticing of an idea
and that's something that more people
can get behind and that's something that
more people will actually give you their
money for because they believe in you
they believe in the message and if
you're aligned on that then you can
partner up and it's going to go well
how much money did you have on the first
day of production for space waves I
think it was like nine thousand dollars
nine or ten thousand yeah
and while you were filming on that first
day
were you thinking about is this going to
carry us through
how or or no it was just this is the
first day we're super excited I mean
yeah we didn't really we didn't know
how we were gonna do it I mean
we we're just so young I mean Andrew was
18 and I was 22 and we did it and so
um yeah it was just kind of like hey we
have 10K let's hope it lasts for these
next three weeks on production but
um yeah we didn't really know what we
what we were doing or if it was going to
work but we just walked in faith and we
just
um we went hard every single day and we
put
um put our A-game into it 100 the whole
way there
how many days were you able to film
before that money ran out we got through
the whole principal photography yeah so
we got through the 18 shoot days which I
think was like you know three weeks
because we had a few we had a few break
days but um we got through principal
photography just barely and then after
that it was just kind of doing a lot of
pickup shoots so like we'd re-shot the
playground scene or we had to shoot the
classroom scene or bpb News Scene so we
had some different pickups that we had
to do but it was much easier to kind of
raise some money for those or um you
know prepare for those because they were
spread out you know later it wasn't like
oh every single day we're shooting a
scene like how it was on principal
photography
and you're taking everybody from
Southern California and you're driving
how many miles north I don't even know a
lot a lot of miles yeah all the way up
to NorCal all the way up to Grass Valley
so we took all the film equipment that
Biola University let us use
um so we put it all in trailer and drove
up there brought our cast and crew
um up there our our main forecast and
then I think basically everyone else was
hired from NorCal or San Francisco or
something for the other the other roles
in the film where was everyone staying
uh we were staying in my parents house
and then family friends houses so like I
said my parents were super on board very
supportive and so we got to stay in
their place we shot a scene in my uh old
room that I grew up in
and um my parents had friends that let
us stay in their homes and so yeah I
just always say like you know utilize
your resources and whether that be
locations places to
um sleep places to stay whatever
um and just and also just friends and
family for cast members and Extras and
stuff it's like hey come be in my movie
and stuff so just always play to your
strengths and utilize any resources you
have that's what I would say that
probably saved you a ton of money then
yes it did right because we didn't pay
for hardly any locations and space waves
we only paid for a couple
um and that's that's the way it should
be
um and like we were saying earlier off
camera I think it's it's really
um
it's surprising just how many people
will help you out if you just ask like
hey can we film in your driveway can we
film in your little small mom and pop
business you know
um it doesn't it never hurts to ask and
a lot of people will be interested and a
lot of people will be excited about
having their location in a film so I
always try to get every location or as
many locations as I can for free and so
far it's been going good
so that's part of the small town
Hospitality yeah they wanted to see you
succeed but if you had done it down here
probably would have been a little
tougher definitely but sort of similar
down here I mean we were able to shoot
in local connections places so like in a
in a house or an exterior or at Biola
University we're able to use their
Newsroom so you know you can still
utilize your resources even if you live
in SoCal it just might be a little
trickier
what happened when the money did run out
oh man when the money ran out it was
just
Andrew the producer and I
um working like working minimum wage
jobs like right out of college and
saving up money and then being like okay
we've got a few grand okay we're gonna
pay for sound design and then that's
worked on for a few months and then we
save up and then okay we have another
few grand that we're gonna pay for color
grade and then score and so on and so
that's one of the that's like the main
reason the film took so long is because
we just kept running out of money and we
kept having to save up money in order to
just get through the next hurdle and get
through the next phase of
post-production so that was that was
yeah just one of the toughest things of
this whole thing was just constantly
running out of money
um and it really is it tests your mental
fortitude being able to continue with a
project when you're you're halfway in
you're in the thick of it and yeah some
of it's done it's shot or you know sound
design is done but you have all these
other steps that are not done yet it can
be really discouraging and really hard
and for for us as well we had our main
hard drive fail which was devastating
and we thought we had everything backed
up on a backup drive but we were missing
one scene and so we had to spend the
money that we were going to spend on
like our sound design like a few
thousand dollars we had to spend that
money on getting the main hard drive
repaired so that set us back like I
don't even know how many months like
three or six months or something because
then we had to save up again and then
put the money in to get the next phase
of you know sound done or whatever so
there are things like that that'll
happen that you have to be aware of and
that you have to just
um get through in every film there's
going to be challenges like that at
least you could Salvage it yes that's
yeah wow that's good yeah because you
had the bulk of it you said the 18 days
we were pretty much in the can okay and
then just one scene was hadn't been
backed up and we were like okay either
we reshoot it but that wasn't really
viable or we have to pay to get the hard
drive
um recovered and so we ended up doing
that
how did you raise the additional forty
thousand
um like I said it was just a lot of it
was mostly a lot of self-funding and
then
um I think we ran yeah we ran a second
Indiegogo campaign once we had shot like
principal photography so people could
see clips from the film which was cool
um and so that helped a lot you know
it's like hey this is what the film
could look like here's some shots from
it
um and you know people get on a moving
train more than they do I I stopped to
train so people were excited about it
people
um gave money to us but yeah most of it
was just self-funded with
um Andrew the producer and myself and
then we had some investors come on at
the very end for probably a total of 10K
um split up between a few different
people and so they have they have equity
in the film
um and then they'll get they'll get paid
out
um as well as Andrew and I
what would you say to someone who says
you can't make a feature film for ten
thousand dollars
uh
um they're just a hater I mean you can
do it anyone can do it
um I think it's also just a question of
how good is the movie going to be you
know with your limited budget so we
started with 10K and we were doing
pretty well but it was one of those
things where we weren't happy with it
and so we took the extra time to reshoot
some things to re-edit some things we
scrapped eight months of sound design
because the first sound designer we
worked with
um just
you know it just wasn't working and so
we said we're not going to settle we're
not going to compromise so we lost all
that work we went and hired someone else
um and so that that's the thing it's
like you can make a movie for very cheap
and um it's you know it'll depend on how
well it turns out or whatever
um it's not like more money means a
better movie
um but it can mean a better movie and in
our case we wanted to spend as little as
possible
um and 50k was about how much it cost
for us to spend as little as possible
while making the best movie that we
could
you had a great camera package too
correct yes yeah what did you shoot on
it's funny because the camera was like
worth our entire budget I think we shot
on the red uh epic dragon and so that
was like a 50 000 camera or whatever
um so that definitely helped being able
to use our film schools equipment
the DP was someone that you also knew
from school yep the DP Conor Griffin was
our classmate and he's an amazing DP and
um we we owe him a lot and he did he did
such a great job
um him and our gaffer and that's another
thing I say is like always try to make
sure you have a good gaffer and good DP
because that that is such a deciding
factor on you know how good your film
looks because if you just have blank
walls or you don't have Dynamic shadows
and stuff in frame it's going to look
cheap it's going to look student film so
really take your lighting and camera
work seriously and also just just be
smart about how you're shooting so I
mean shoot your exteriors in the morning
light and in the evening line then shoot
your Interiors in the daytime you know
um and things things like that basically
just try to be smart with it